manche würden ihn am liebsten da sehen
wo er mal war im knast ein muslim
aufgewachsen als katholischer junge von
seiner mutter im stich gelassen dass er
sein kind in die welt und hat man unter
komplett versagt erst heim und
pflegekind dann mitglied einer
kriminellen bande gewaltbereit und
skrupellos gewalt in deutschen straßen
fand er gerecht verachtete den start
dieser angst verraten tat damals sehr
gefreut
eine islamistische gefährder der jetzt
aussteigen will für immer
es darf nicht irgendwas passieren was
lehren wieder aus die bank aus der bahn
wirft
dann denke ich ist
wir haben uns für ein mehrstündiges
interview verabredet wären recht
spärlich soll uns alles nochmal erzählen
was er bei unserem ersten treffen
ausführlich berichtet hat ändert er
seine geschichte verwickelte er sich in
widersprüche meint er es ernst mit dem
ausstieg
die sicherheitsbehörden haben uns
bestätigt recht spärlich ist als
gefährder eingestuft einer von tausend
in deutschland ein terrorverdächtiger
vielleicht sogar mit kampferfahrung bis
heute noch auch sagen dass im
kriegsgebiet war von journalisten und 20
jetzt würden die mannschaft das bin ich
natürlich immer mal darf überall urlaub
machen und von daher bin ich wenn ich
das einmal
also sie schließen es nicht aus ich sage
nein ein jahr könnte ihn ins gefängnis
bringen mitgliedschaft in einer
ausländischen terroristischen
vereinigung paragraph 129b strafgesetz
die behörden bezweifeln dass ehrenrat
sperrig im krieg war mit dem ios oder al
qaida aber einen anschlag hier trauen
sie ihm jederzeit zu er sei eine
bedrohung für die bundesrepublik
deutschland so heißt es zweiter juli
2017 mitten in düsseldorf startet die
tour de france zehntausende säumen die
straße kurz zuvor stürmte ein
spezialeinsatzkommando red sperlichs
wohnung dabei war es dann meine haustür
ganz laut aufgesprungen geschrei auf dem
boden polizei sonst schießen wir ich
habe es natürlich auch viele kinder
holten gemacht man hat mir meine hände
drei bm karl binder verbunden man hat
mir direkt so ein sack über den kopf
gezogen und meine augen verbunden
dann habe ich dann angezogen so sagen
diese sondereinsatzkommando war sehr
sehr freundlich also war nicht
gewaltbereit wie es von anderen sachen
kenne deine frage angestiegen wenn ich
frei habe den das dann beantwortet dann
wurde dann auch wirklich fast also nur
ein t shirt und jeans hose so dass
sicher war weil wir um einen kopf in ein
auto verbracht und wir wollen an die
augen wieder aufgemacht in russland in
polizeigewahrsam gebracht
ist red spärlich wirklich so gefährlich
dokumente belegen seine engen
verbindungen in die islamistische szene
und seine festnahme wegen mutmaßlicher
staatsgefährdung erfand pc kennt so
etwas aus eigener erfahrung wie red
spärlich galt pc einst als
terrorverdächtiger später arbeitete der
ehemalige islam ist für den
verfassungsschutz jetzt überzeugt der
junge menschen vom irrsinn des
islamismus im auftrag des bundestages
wir prüfen die lebensgeschichte von
ehren red spärlich dem 25 jährigen aus
zerrütteten verhältnissen später
mitglied einer jugendbande dann auch
islam ist gewaltbereit
ausgerechnet so einer arbeitete bis vor
kurzem noch in einer sicherheitsfirma
aber beginnen wir von vorne das
kinderheim in düren red felix mutter
wollte ihren sohn nicht haben heimpflege
familien so eine kindheit ist keine
rechtfertigung für das was aus ihm wurde
aber teil einer erklärung
was macht das mit reinen wenn man in
folge genommen keine mutter kein vater
eigentlich hat als kleinsten realisiert
das glaube ich nicht
klawitter bezugsperson sein
hat mich aber sehr gefestigte beziehung
gesagt mich wenn ich sage es war nicht
nur schlechte tage sind auch schöne tage
die sollte man aufnehmen
wie war das hier kann man das
beschreiben als behütetes zuhause auch
hier im kinderheim ja sehr christlich
oder genetische tischgebet war durch
einen kindergarten jungjäger war ja der
grundschule eine sexistische sie wusste
noch nicht dass sie eigentlich einen
muslimen sind haben sie das erfahren wo
ich her wo ich das meiner mutter wieder
gezogen
das heißt also die gesamte zeit
kinderheim auch in den familien wussten
sie nichts davon
für alle war ehren ein katholischer
junge mit fremdländischen namen ja aber
akzeptiert und glücklich auch später in
seiner familie in langenfeld glaube 12
münchen die pflege von mir nach
langenfeld gezogen
diese familie habe ich auch wirklich
sehr gemocht bist dann eines tages
meiner mutter vor die haustür stand also
ich dass da konnte ich mich an meine
mutter wirklich erinnern und die
erzählung dann eines tages stand einfach
meine mutter vor der haustür und wollte
was da ich zurückkommen
wie reagiert fragen sehen 12 13 jährige
jungen wo wir zerlegen
bei deiner pflege wieder bei seiner
mutter jeder normale mini zeigt bei
deiner mutter aber ich glaube für mich
war es damals
einer der größten fehler die ich
begangen habe sei eine katastrophe in
einem halben jahr wieder ins kinderheim
kommen nach düsseldorf ja dann war mir
alles egal hat einfach alles gemacht
man hatte keinen halt nur zu mir kleine
kleine straftaten gemacht aber ich war
ja noch hinterher wieder sondern konnte
mir nichts in anführungsstrichen ja für
mich irgendwie das gefühl keiner wollte
mich haben und dann habe ich irgendwie
mein leben gelebt
ich denke ich an falsch aber ist jetzt
erst ein kind in die welt wenn ich mich
um das kind kümmern kann man sollte man
kann frei entscheiden ob ein kind in die
welt setzen nicht und wenn ich den fuß
gefasst habe dass ich ein kind erziehen
kann sollte er sein kind in die welt und
hat meine mutter komplett versagt um
jedem missverständnis vorzubeugen
niemand sollte mitleid mit ihm haben
meinte auch ihren selbst und führt uns
an den ort seiner ersten schandtaten
hier in mönchengladbach rheydt war er
einer der anführer einer kriminellen
bande
die jugendlichen haben gestohlen geraubt
und die ihre beute in seiner wohnung
versteckt und sie waren
wir haben eine zeit langsam reicht also
meine eigenen waffe la morocha gas holen
und so habe ich akustisch immer da
versteckt dass ich immer noch bereichert
weil die wohnungen durchsucht das war ja
die aktion und vielleicht habe ich habe
ja einer software auf leute geschossen
da kann ich wohl diesmal aber nicht
reinlassen mit der softgun hier am
fenster auf leute geschossen warum hat
langeweile aber so ok und so nachhinein
zeichen weil gewalt natürlich den leuten
weh getan hätte ich ein auge getroffen
hätten die blind werden können und so
auch damals war schon cool
nach allem was er erzählt war es seine
zeit der enthemmung
sie waren ihren familien und der
gesellschaft offenbar gleichgültig also
rechten sie sich es ging nicht so sehr
um das geld aus den raubzügen sondern um
anerkennung innerhalb der gruppe und
darüber ungehindert ungestraft alles tun
zu können
respekt vor dem leben und der
unversehrtheit anderer beinahe 0 durch
echte weiterhin 90 dabei keiner land
schlagstock ein butterflymesser ist ein
fan seinen kiosk eingegangen weil er
geweint hat am boden
okay das ist eigentlich das was ich
möchte obwohl ich ein bisschen ans geld
gedacht habe weil mit dem geld kann ich
ja andere sachen finanzieren dann habe
ich die frau schreien hören und wenn ja
war ausgegangen
ein intensivstraftäter 16 jahre alt
immer noch auf der suche nach identität
und zugehörigkeit nicht weit vom ort
seiner verbrechen glaubte er all das zu
finden was war hier früher
wir haben uns hierfür auf der eigenen
straße aufgehalten
hier standen hier damals ob die brüder
das waren die glaubensbrüder jene
moscheen mönchengladbach eicken die
längst abgerissen ist
sie war ein hort des salafismus einer
extremistischen strömungen im islam ihre
anhänger sehen sich und ihre religion
als opfer westlicher politik auch ehren
sah sich als opfer
das verbindet der größten der punkt war
glaube ich
der zusammenhalt also es ist eine riesen
familie
man könnte jetzt ein ich könnte jetzt
einen angerufen der mond in berlin für
sagen ich komme morgen billigen kannst
du mich auf wenn wir sofort ja sagen
diese reichweite dieser zusammenhang
dass seine komplette familie
das hat mich sehr gereizt damals man
muss schon vorstellen hier war dann für
hier war alles voll
wurde hier im markt da war die bühne
gereizt hat ihn auch die provokation
hier forderten die salafisten die
deutsche gesellschaft heraus beriefen
sich auf meinungs- und religionsfreiheit
obwohl die doch in einem islamistischen
staat sofort abgeschafft wird
sie luden hass prediger wie pierre vogel
ein die den fruchtbaren boden bereiten
für die rechtfertigung von gewalt im
namen allahs und manche hier beteiligten
sich später auch am jihad in syrien
besorgte bürger in mönchengladbach macht
mobil sie fühlten sich vom staat ein
stück weit im stich gelassen
[Applaus]
genau das wollten die salafisten mit
ihren aktionen erreichen
hat man sich über die anwohner lustig
gemacht dann natürlich wir haben die
verspottet hat ja eh nichts was soll wir
machen
die bei den islam unserer eigenen
sicherheit uns voraus und sind wir mal
ist das bewusste provokation gewesen
oder ist das jetzt haben wir auch eine
gewisse arroganz dass man sagt hier in
einer freien gesellschaft wir können
sowieso nichts dagegen unternimmt eine
provokation und natürlich zeigen können
wir können hier machen wir wollen wo es
teure gesellschaft wir verabscheuen euch
das restliche leben
aber machen wir was wir wollen auf
einmal hatten diebstähle und einbrüche
für ihren eine neue bedeutung ohne das
wissen der anderen bandenmitglieder
zweigte er geld aus dem verkauf der
beute ab für seine neue familie
man nimmt das geld den ungläubigen und
gibt es wenn wir das geklärt eingangs
verkauft und dann haben wir das geld
aufgeteilt ich habe noch ein bisschen
mehr genommen damit das geld deiner
seite legen kann
ich habe auch andere straftat machen
lassen wo ich in der tabelle das nichts
bei raus gekommen
das geld dann abgezogen dann
weitergegeben hatten sie den eindruck
das geld wird hier verwendet oder wird
das geld dann was wir sich gesammelt ist
es so umfangreich ist dass man es
vielleicht in kriegs und krisengebieten
wir die rede da für krankenhäuser
krankenwagen kaufen möchten medizin
verbandsmaterial essen trinken kleidung
kaufen möchten
mai 2012
deutschlands top salafisten bei einem
protest in borth ehrenrat spärlich saß
damals seine erste haftstrafe ab nachdem
ihn ein gangmitglied an die polizei
verraten hat
aber er erfuhr dass die demo in bonn in
gewalt umschlug ein salafist murat k
griff polizisten mit einem messer an
verletzte mehrere beamte schwer
statt abscheu empfand ehren bewunderung
[Applaus]
klar war es vielleicht gezielt weil er
agitiert in körperlich doch die nicht
geschützt sind bei polizisten die auch
bei so gewaltbereit leuten trainiert
wird dann natürlich hat mich diese
inzwischen an staaten tat damals sehr
gefreut spielte das opfer oder die opfer
sind mehrere verletzt worden eine sehr
schwer für sie gar keine rolle weil ich
ja selbst polizei heute erlebt habe am
eigenen leib was toleranz aus dem
gefängnis heraus hatte ehren kontakt zu
einem rädelsführer der szene abeba
[Applaus]
sollte der raum ist nicht
abu ibraheem alias hassan keskin wurde
zu einem vorbild galt als gefährder der
sich nicht nur an der straßengewalt wie
hier in solingen beteiligte die behörden
trauten keskin terroranschläge zu er
gehörte zur sogenannten milito ibrahim
die gruppe wurde verboten zahlreiche
mitglieder schlossen sich später den
nissan wohl auch hasan kesting
das kind wird ja immer noch nach wie vor
gesucht zum jetzigen zeitpunkt man
vermutet dass er einen syrien sein soll
und sich dann erst angeschlossen hat
habe sie unmittelbaren kontakt mit ihm
gehabt haben sie ihn da kennen gelernt
warum es kennen gelernt oder weniger hat
mir auch definiert wagen geschrieben
wir besuchen die jva iserlohn in der red
spärlich bis 2014 einsatz damals so
bestätigt uns die sozialarbeiterin gab
es noch keine dichten gitter vor den
fenstern seines zellentrakt
abends verteilten sie die handys die
freunde über die mauer geworfen hat so
konnten die gefangenen dann unbemerkt
nach draußen kommunizieren sie mussten
die geräte nur gut verstecken herren
hatte zeitweise mehrere dutzend
mobiltelefone
er zeigt uns seine zelle auf den ersten
blick gibt es hier wenig möglichkeiten
etwas zu verbergen
aber die häftlinge waren ideen im
schrank socke in der lampe über dem
schreibtisch hinter dem spiegel im bad
im türstock ehren hatte geklaute am
ziegel mit denen er nach öffnen und
schließen das versteck der mobiltelefone
wieder versiegeln konnte
kommt man hier ins grübeln ob man was
falsch gemacht wird wenn man jede welle
zugebracht hat natürlich und beim namen
dann macht man sich schon ein paar
bekannten gut oder schlecht
sowohl als auch im endeffekt war hier
weiter bergauf zeit für mich meiner
meinung nach war recht diese konnte viel
faxen machen
da habe ich immer gute erinnerungen in
guter erinnerung hat auch katja würmern
den damals 20-jährigen das ehren eng mit
der islamistischen szene vernetzt war
fiel erst kurz vor dem ende seiner
haftzeit auf der umgang war ein bis
einen monat vor seiner haft ganz normal
er hat mitgearbeitet am vollzugs ziel er
wollte vermittelt werden in eine
wohngruppe in ein internat in ein
sportinternat und das war ja im november
alles weg plötzlich spielt seine
vorgeschichte seine kindheit norde dabei
wie er dann sich erstens in die
kriminelle und später in die
islamistische szene entwickelt hat ja im
prinzip hatte der ehren nie wirklich
familie gelebt also er hat meine mutter
und vater aber immer wenn er beziehung
zu menschen geknüpft hat familiäre
strukturen erlebt dann sind die
weggebrochen und letztendlich hat der
iren mir mal gesagt also eigentlich ist
das hier schon mein zuhause und hier
habe ich endlich personen auf die ich
mich verlassen kann und die mich nicht
fallen lassen und deswegen war es
natürlich auch geplant dass er nach der
entlassung im bogendruck geht ein sport
internat hätte sein leben verändert denn
ehren war ein klasse fußballer viola
fiedler sein trainer bestätigt mit dem
team der jva durfte er im normalen
ligabetrieb außerhalb des gefängnisses
mitspielen war sogar mannschaftskapitän
das wird man auch nicht so kapitän bei
uns bis heute wird auch nicht gewählt
sondern letztendlich
legen die hauptsächlich als zuständiger
für die fußballmannschaft wir gucken
schon die jungs aus die dazu passen
und dazu ist eben nicht nur wichtig dass
der junge ruf zerstören kann sondern er
muss auch einiges mitbringen so eine
mannschaft für sich ist ein spiegelbild
von draußen aber er muss verbindungsmann
zum trainer sein muss zuverlässig seien
regelmäßig zum training kommen natürlich
auch ein gewisses potenzial das als
fußballer haben und das brachte er
nehmen damals alles mit ihm gesagt als
kapitän kann ja auch nicht jeder spielen
hat mich als auch geehrt gefühlt aber
trotzdem war es meiner meinung nach
trotzdem etwas verlogenes von mir weil
ich im endeffekt etwas vorgespielt hat
mehr oder weniger klar beim sport kann
sich komplett abschalten
aber sobald ich auf dem sportplatz
gegangen bin wusste ich okay was
deutlich gefallen aber ich mache aber im
endeffekt hat sich sparen also nicht
wirklich interessiert und beeinflusst
falscher konnte es nicht laufen ein
echtes talent obendrein auch ein immer
verlässlicher gerätewarte in der
sporthalle und doch gleichzeitig eben
auch ein verblendeter islamist
er war aber auch so von seinem
sozialverhalten dass wir uns immer auf
ihn verlassen konnten
wir kamen immer zum training er war
immer pünktlich und er war auch immer
für die mannschaft auch immer da ich
persönlich war auch nachher sehr davon
überrascht als das hier in der anstalt
das thema aufgaben das ehren
mit diesem thema überhaupt was zu tun
haben könnte und das war für mich in der
tat auch eine überraschung
auf der anderen seite auch ein stück
auch enttäuschung muss ich im nachhinein
muss ich das so sagen weil wir ehren
gegenüber sehr offen auch immer waren
dass wir eben auch zugehört haben dass
wir immer gesprächsbereit mann wenn er
probleme hatten dass wir ihm ratschläge
und tipps gegeben man anscheinend hat es
da aber auch parallel verhalten von ihm
gegeben was uns erst im nachhinein
bewusst geworden ist ein doppeltes spiel
trieb ehren gern als er durch seinen
kontakt zu abu ibraheem als islamist
aufflog meldete er sich für das
aussteigerprogramm des
verfassungsschutzes an aussteigen
und warum haben sie es dann gemacht also
für um vorteile zu erlangen
ja genau das hat keiner gemerkt erzählen
sie wie war das
wir wollen ein paar lachen müssen dann
haben mich einige sachen gefragt ich ja
beantwortet habe teil sachen die
gestimmt haben womit die auch alle
arbeiten konnten die man nachprüfen
konnte weil ich den ja was erzählen
musste womit die mich auch
identifizieren können ob ich auch
wirklich zähne und ich bin so was alles
wird das habe ich noch gesagt dann habe
ich auch irgendwo erzählt die die
einfach hören wollten damit die ruhe
lassen und ich halte auch immer wieder
wenn er hat ja nichts ging also das was
ich wollte hab ich dir müssen was kein
problem ich ruf gerne verfassungsschutz
an erklären dass bestimmte für mich und
habe dann alles möglich erzählt
alles mögliche über die salafisten szene
die in deutschland 2014 rasant an bugs
aufgestachelt von prediger wie pierre
vogel den red spärlich persönlich kannte
inspiriert durch den vormarsch des sie
es in syrien und irak viele folgten dem
ruf zur ausreise in die kriegsgebiete
aber denise und seine greueltaten so
sagt red spärlich habe er abstoßen
gefunden
er suchte die nähe zu bernhard fallt der
erhobene zeigefinger gilt als propaganda
geste der salafisten er signalisiert den
glauben an den einen gott
bernhard falk ist als gefährder
eingestuft einst vorurteil zu 13 jahren
haft wegen sprengstoffverbrechen und
vierfachen mordversuchs heute so sagen
die ermittler rekrutiere er anhänger für
al qaida falk bestreitet das er reist
durch die republik um islamisten bei
gerichtsverfahren zu beraten welche
rolle spielt für al kaida in deutschland
eine große rolle ist er der anführer der
al kaida in deutschland
er sagt ja nicht wirklich viel dazu zum
thema weil er möchte nicht belastbar
sein wenn man mit ihm spricht weiß man
dass al qaida ist ich gehe davon aus
dass falk eine sehr nach stehende person
zu al qaida hat auch wirklich sehr
nachstehend ist zurzeit auch mit denen
kommuniziert recht spärlich behauptet
über fax kontakte die er mit einem alten
abhörsicheren handy pflege bestens
informiert zu sein
er habe in feix auftrag und in seiner
vertretung mehrfach als beobachter an
prozessen teilgenommen das verhältnis
sei eng und vertrauensvoll gewesen fallt
mehr als nur ein berater
aber das habe ich gesagt eine person die
wie mein vater ist wir haben uns fast
täglich getroffen man habe täglich mehr
richtungen miteinander verbracht wenn
man sozusagen seine rechte hand geworden
also er besuchte ja in ganz deutschland
prozessor wenn er manchen energie war
war ich dann halt bei den prozessen in
nrw den fall von murat k dem messer
angreifer von bonn hat falk selbst
betreut
während alle nur über den es reden so
behauptet sperrig diene falk als
kontaktmann der al kaida in deutschland
auch für mögliche gewalttaten al kaida
ist ja sehr ruhig momentan hat der kaum
was von al kaida und die organisation
schläft er nicht was macht ihr hier in
deutschland die organisation
ich bin ich immer sehr kundig seit
einigen monaten oder jetzt weiß halt so
nicht mehr wirklich viel darüber
aber damals war der zeitpunkt dass sich
ein neuer karosserie in deutschland
gründet köln im schatten des mächtigen
doms haben wir uns mit bernhard falk
verabredet um ihn mit den vorwürfen zu
konfrontieren
falk bestreitet einen wirklich
intensiven kontakt mit ähren red
schwerlich eine art vaterfigur
da sei wohl der wunsch der vater des
gedankens gewesen und al kaida
er sagt dass sie der al kaida vertreter
in deutschland sein
können sie sich das erklären
na gut es gibt medienberichte die
bestimmte dinge über mich behaupten und
er ist sicher nicht uninformiert also
dass er googelt hat davon gehe ich aus
ich habe mit ihm keine politischen
tieferen diskussionen geführt und oder
sie vielleicht direkten kontakt zu al
kaida haben entweder direkt sie selber
oder über mittelsmänner ja es steht
ihnen frei alles mögliche zu behaupten
das wird aber dadurch natürlich nicht
den tatsachen entsprechend also es gab
keinen kontakt zu ehren derart dass er
überhaupt beurteilen könnte mit wem ich
im laufe der 24 stunden pro tag zu tun
habe und es ist auch nicht so gewesen
dass er mir irgendwie die arbeit
besonders erleichtert hätte oder welche
materiellen zuwendungen für mich
organisiert hätte oder irgendetwas ich
habe es für richtig gehalten dass ein
junger mann der auf orientierungssuche
es und frisch aus der haft kommt sicher
die ein oder andere beratung von mir
bekommt
aber mehr oder weniger mehr
als telefongespräche im letztlich waren
das nicht das foto 111 ii nach einer
zufallsbegegnung der zeigefinger nicht
mehr als ein glaubensbekenntnis red
spärlich behauptet mit berna falk über
mögliche anschlagsziele gesprochen zu
haben
haben sie über ziele wie amerikanische
militäreinrichtungen mal mit ihm geredet
weil er leicht was machen wollte
überhaupt nicht also ich habe überhaupt
nicht vor allen dingen müssen sie ein
mensch der unter bewährung steht das
heißt also wir hatten ganz andere themen
als da irgendwie militanter aktivitäten
zu besprechen
es ist überhaupt noch nicht einmal
thematisiert worden
es ist auch nicht über gruppen
ausgesprochen worden es ist der dazu war
der kontakt einfach nicht intensiv genug
in einer e mail schreibt falk uns später
von einem gezielten treffen und mehreren
zufälligen begegnungen bei telefonaten
sei es um wohnungs und arbeitsplatzsuche
sowie ratschläge zum verhalten bei
überwachung und durchsuchungen gegangen
in jener zeit war der krieg gegen den es
in syrien im vollen gange aber
ausgerechnet über ideologie und terror
gruppen will falk mit ähren recht
spärlich nie gesprochen haben
obwohl doch beide damals aus ihrem hass
gegen die amerikanische militär politik
keinen hehl machten
fast folgerichtig tauchte dann dieses
foto auf aber zeigt es wirklich einen
kampf bereiten ehrenrat schnell ich
vielleicht in einem trainingslager an
wort bei der handlung auch ein foto
veröffentlicht man erkennt mich ein
freund meines muttermals im auge wo ich
mit einer täuschend echten
maschinenpistole stehen würde bzw
vermummten wo dann die sagen nämlich der
wie kam das zustande
langeweile war sage ich nach wie vor
noch nicht tatsächlich irgendwo
ausgereist und ein trainingslager
mitgemacht oder ähnliches nachweisen
also da man damals wenig beweisen kann
raich war hier in deutschland in einem
keller aus langeweile aus langeweile
viele zurück in alte muster beginn
straftaten landete wieder in haft zeigte
offen seine islamistische gesinnung
griff einen gefängnisaufseher an und
musste dafür hier in der jva aachen
büßen
dann kann sich in isolationshaft das hat
sich stark geändert wie muss man sich
isolationshaft vorstellen dass vielen
sonnenstunden eigentlich wird man hatte
von allen eine schöne freistunde die
machen die aber da morgens um 6 uhr 7
und wie man zu schikanieren
also ich bin dann auch morgens extra
ausgegangen wenn es geregnet hat dann
müssten ja auch draußen stehen dann die
nass werden war für mich kein problem
ich hatte kein richtiges gesteckt vater
sohn hundenapf wo ich essen musste drin
einzel durch öffnete mit drei vier
bedienstete nachts immer licht anmachen
die tür klopfen und ich wach bin und so
dass alles eine zeitlang mir meine
ganzen islamischen sachen mitgenommen
fernseher weggenommen
ich dachte kein wasser kochen
also was soll mir weggenommen etwas ihre
islamistische überzeugung eher noch
gestärkt ich bin hier noch radikaler
geworden dass man die beantragte gehen
oder beziehungsweise über über sachen
nachdenkt und man sich bei den leuten ja
ist den leuten auszeichnung zu zahlen
bzw dem deutschen staat
wie war das als sie dann raus kamen was
wie würden sie sich beschreiben als in
welchem status weil sie als ist beim ist
zu diesem zeitpunkt dass selbst die
sicherheit würden sagen man hätte man
mir in der zeit am anfang zu entlassen
entweder ein anschlag zugetraut hätte
damit fest gerechnet ich ausgereist zu
wäre wäre auch fast dazu gekommen
wenn ich nicht bestimmte personen im
umfeld hätte dann macht man entlassung
unmittelbar nach der haft war der damals
23 jährige zur gewalt entschlossen die
sicherheitsbehörden stuften ihn als
gefährder ein sind sich aber bis heute
nicht sicher ob er selbst anschläge
verüben wollte ehren behauptet zu
logistischer unterstützung sei er bereit
gewesen
gab es da konkrete anschlagsplanung es
war stand mal was im raum
aber es dann nicht mehr weitergeführt
wer sollte das pflügen diese personen
leben nicht mehr in deutschland
und was für ein szenario wäre der
anschlag gewesen
aber möchte nicht reden aber innerhalb
deutschlands ja und was was haben sie
damals gedacht wir haben sie da getickt
weil das hätte er eingeschlossen selbst
hält sich selber nicht einmal anschlag
beteiligt gewesen wäre sie werden an der
vorbereitung beteiligt gewesen es werden
menschen dabei gestorben wie wie haben
sie sich das selber gerechtfertigt mit
dem hass gegen die westliche
gesellschaft
was heißt das warum das hätte ja mehr
oder weniger r behörden trocken bzw
etwas getroffen dass eine
sicherheitsbarriere oderland oder wo
leute von der sich jetzt wo er sich
aufhalten mehr oder weniger und dann
daher sind das leute die die szene
damals bekämpft hat und da ist das für
mich nicht relevant gewesen also
staatliche einrichtungen gewissermaßen
nicht irgendwo wie wir es in den letzten
jahren erlebt haben anschläge auf einem
weihnachtsmarkt oder mitten in den
straßen der stadt borken mit der stadt
aber zu dem zeitpunkt bewerten da
natürlich auch zivilisten gewesen aber
auch sicher hätte man dann keinen
unterschied gemacht also wenn jetzt
zivilisten gestorben wären die nicht für
den staat gearbeitet haben wurde das
trotzdem gerechtfertigt es gibt so ein
satz den ich mal aufgefangen habe in der
szene wo gehobelt
wo gehobelt wird fallen späne den satz
wurde immer wieder mal gesagt wie denken
sie heute darüber
ich kenne mich als person wenn ich
zurück erkenne ich mich gar nicht mehr
hat mich ja komplett gedreht und finden
dass man eigentlich einen damals
katastrophal war warum weil
das nichts mit dem islam zu tun hat es
hat ja was mit der verfassung der
männchen instruktionen der westlichen
gesellschaft zu tun
der islam ist die friedliche religion
ich kenne und der islam für tolerant
konkreten das hat nichts mit terror zu
tun
ein anschlag mitten in der stadt
so wie dieser in berlin ein langer weg
vom jungen aus dem kinderheim zum gang
mitglied vom talentierten fußballer zum
überzeugten islamisten vom terroristen
und mörder anis amri hätte ihn am ende
nichts mehr unterschieden und ehren
hätte die gelegenheit gehabt denn er
arbeitete als ordner und wachmann für
eine sicherheitsfirma bei fußballspielen
zum beispiel und bei der tour de france
am 2 juli 2017 startete die erste etappe
des gesamt fels in düsseldorf die
begleitautos wurden von einem
sicherheitsdienst bewacht hinter dem
dorint hotel in mönchengladbach sollte
ehren aufpassen dass sich niemand an den
fahrzeugen zu schaffen macht es
schwierig wäre es für sie selbst gewesen
was an den autos manipulieren
da einfach weil ja auch keine
kameraüberwachung ist es gibt eine
kamera hier aber komplett auf das kann
man oft das parkhaus selber wird das
parkdeck keine kameras also für mich was
kinder einfach gewesen
also wenn man hier irgendwas in einem
begleitfahrzeug oder unter 1 befestigen
wollte wäre es kein problem wäre noch
richtig was hätte sein können
sprengsätzen oder ich gehe jetzt wenn
man das macht also hätte ich das gemacht
was auch vermutet irgendwie herr ansteht
war üben
wer hier die optimale möglichkeit
gewesen dass man es hier zwar daran
befestigt aber dass die explosion dann
möglicherweise ganz woandershin korrekt
dutzende von menschen hätten sterben
können deshalb wurde ehren an jenem
morgen vom sek präventiv festgenommen er
hatte keinen anschlag geplant war aber
ein sicherheitsrisiko neutralisiert auf
den letzten drücker
denn das sicherheitspersonal nicht
vorher überprüft eigentlich schon aber
sich jetzt was auf dem server sun meldet
gibt es gar nicht die zeit um reagieren
um sicher zu machen
das heißt also sicherheitsunternehmen
die ihr personal stellen wissen gar
nicht genau ob sie ihren eigenen leuten
trauen können richtig manche sicher dem
wissen das ja dass die leute vorbestraft
sind und deswegen werde ich 34 50 wagen
gestellt damit die anderen unternehmen
für die daran arbeiten kann sich jetzt
wirklich machen können das bedeutet man
vermeidet bewusst eine
sicherheitsüberprüfung indem man sie
auch entsprechend niedriger basis
einstellt ja korrekt wie war das bei
ihnen hat irgendjemand gefragt was sie
für eine vorgeschichte
es klingt unglaublich aber für unsere
fachberater ihren pc ist das keine
überraschung
er hat sich die sicherheitsbranche in
deutschland näher angesehen
tatsächlich werden immer wieder
kriminelle und islamisten von kleinen
subunternehmen beschäftigt die oft für
große event agenturen arbeiten bei
längerfristig beschäftigten müssen die
firmen die fachliche eignung der
mitarbeiter nachweisen inklusive
polizeilichen führungszeugnis aber bei
aushilfskräften kurzfristig auf 450 euro
basis angeheuert müsste das
gewerbeaufsichtsamt prüfen das hat aber
weder personal noch zeit für so eine
kurzfristige prüfung
rock am ring im sommer 2017 alles ist
bereit für eine riesenfete da kommt die
absage
angeblich soll ein islamist als ordner
beim größten rock festival deutschlands
tätig sein
der schaden für fans und veranstalter
ist riesig es später wird sich
herausstellen dass der verdächtige gar
nicht eingesetzt wurde
marek lieberberg chef der konzertagentur
ist stinksauer
lieberberg sieht auch veranstalter und
sicherheitsfirmen in der pflicht
defizite zu beheben und das erwartet er
auch von den behörden gerade das
gefährde umfeld so schreibt er uns muss
permanent im fokus der ermittler seien
damit gefahren frühzeitig erkannt und
abgewehrt werden können
aber der begriff gefährder ist eben
keine strafrechtliche kategorie so
erfahren sicherheitsfirmen nicht davon
wenn einer ihrer mitarbeiter ein
extremistisches und erkenntnisse über
ihn bei staatsschutz behörden vorliegen
er fand pc hat dafür zahlreiche
beispiele gefunden
facebook profile von überzeugten
islamisten die in der sicherheitsbranche
beschäftigt sind judenhass hass auf den
westen seine politik und seine werte
werden da verbreitet
wacken anfang august 2008 10
zehntausende menschen rocken ab
friedlich
damit das so sein kann sind hunderte von
ordnern und sicherheitsleuten eingesetzt
sie kontrollieren am eingang jeden
beutel jeden rucksack um gefahren von
den fans fernzuhalten
eigentlich müssten alle mitarbeiter der
wachdienste überprüft sein irgendwo auf
dem platz ist einer von ihnen mit dabei
der stolz die fotos von seiner
akkreditierung und vom
veranstaltungsgelände in den sozialen
medien posten
wenn er nicht gerade bei so einem event
arbeitet verbreitet er auf seinem profil
ganz andere inhalte islamistische
propaganda sympathie für den ds
genugtuung über anschläge gegen
polizisten
ein anderer wachmann teilt offenbar
solche ansichten wie sein
facebook-profil belegt er habe schon mal
veranstaltungen mit prominenten bewacht
steht da nach zdf-informationen ist er
wegen seiner überzeugungen im blick des
verfassungsschutzes
die sicherheitsbehörden sind gesucht
denn in propagandavideos fordern
deutschsprachiges kämpfer ihre anhänger
in deutschland nicht nur zu spenden auf
sie sollen sich aktiv beteiligen auch
durch terroranschläge meist genanntes
ziel ist berlin
deshalb müssen gefährder rund tausend
sind es hierzulande jederzeit mit
präventiver festnahme rechnen sowie
ehren bei der tour de france das
ermittlungsverfahren so belegt dieses
dokument ist mittlerweile eingestellt
seit diesem erlebnis so sagt er in red
sperrig wolle er raus aus dem islamismus
und zwar endgültig
das fragt man sich natürlich wollen sie
aussteigen
ich habe letztes jahr eine person
kennengelernt
und diese person hat mir etwas gegeben
was ich die alte gesucht habe diese
zusammenhalt
familiäre bindungen also all das was
wonach ich gesucht habe damals in der
szene
mit der person sehr froh diese ganze
sache nicht vorgehabt gesagt wir sollen
auch vom tag eins jetzt mal so ich habe
diesen staat ich habe das gemacht das
war bei der tour de france dem
siegreichen quartett macht man ja wohl
ausgestellt und man hat nicht um
sprengstoff und meine wohnung durch so
geil dass da so ein schild nach wie vor
immer noch zu mir heute auch noch
und sie war groß und so hat einen großen
schritt beigetragen dass ich jetzt jede
mit ihm vor der kamera stehen sie hat
mich als mensch wahrgenommen und ich als
meine vergangenheit hat mich und mein
charakter jetzt genommen wie ich bin
haben wir die letzten gedanken bezüglich
damals ein junge nation nach hause
genommen und kann mit viel freude sagen
dass robert das ist personalleiter steht
nach wie vor also sich nicht wo der weg
hin gegangen werden
es muss so gewesen wer aber meint er ist
wirklich ehrlich immerhin geht ehren mit
seinem vollen namen erkennbar für
jedermann vor die kamera um seine
geschichte zu erzählen
das könnte nicht ungefährlich sein wenn
er als verräter gesehen wird denn in
einem anderen fall wurde dem aussteiger
über die sozialen medien gedroht wie
einen hund solle man ihn abschlachten
zur abschreckung für andere
klar muss ich mit einer mit einem
gesunden zweifel daran gehören diese
ganze geschichte jetzt in der
öffentlichkeit mit der ganzen sache wenn
es publik ist ich weiß aber wenn einer
kommt wie ich mich verteidigen muss und
letztendlich gibt es dafür die
sicherheitsbehörden die bahn ihre arbeit
richtig machen müssen um mich schützen
müssen april 2018 in münster rast ein
kleinbus in ein straßencafé vier tote 20
verletzte der täter erschießt sich
der amokfahrer so stellt sich später
heraus handelte nicht aus
extremistischen motiven dennoch
klingelte die polizei auf der suche nach
mitwissern auch bei ihren recht spärlich
dass die ermittler ihn weiter als gefahr
für andere sehen darin gibt er nur einem
die schuld sich selbst
man kann immer gut sagen ja also ein
anderer schuld man kann gut die ich holt
anderen nicht schuhe schieben
welche ziele setzt also sagen wir dass
ein anderes schuld wären wir an dem
punkt wo ich vor einigen jahren war und
würde ausreden suchen
klar gibt es situationen mein leben die
nicht gut gelaufen sind die vielleicht
den weg ein bisschen mit entschieden
haben
aber ich finde ein eigener man kann
selbst entscheidungen treffen und wenn
ganz so ganz allein und selbst schuld
dass es so gekommen das ist gekommen
ich mache da kann man froh wären wir nie
mehr in den knast erst 25 hat eine feste
beziehung ein arbeitsplatz wirkte
entschlossen der staatsschutz hält es
für möglich dass er es schaffen kann
aber schaffte es also wenn ich ihnen
jetzt so sehr und kann ich mir das gut
vorstellen aber wie gesagt nach es darf
nicht irgendwas passieren was ehren
wieder aus die bei aus der bahn wirft
dann denke ich ist in gefahr er und dann
hat er hoffentlich kontaktpersonen an
jährlich werden kann
was mich vor allen dingen persönlich
sehr zuversichtlich stimmt ist die
beziehung der beziehungsstatus nur für
seine frau oder seine wohnung hat und
was eben meine eigene arbeit betrifft
eben dass er auch zum beispiel aus dem
sportverein tätig ist weil da fiel eben
über diese gesamte sozialisation drift
und das ist das sind so merkmale die uns
sehr zuversichtlich stimmen dass es
funktionieren kann und von daher
habe ich mich auch sehr gefreut
[Musik]